cada vez que desde certificado aqui do
guinness passa um filme na minha cabeça
imagina depois de sete dias em cima de
uma esteira correndo de 822 quilômetros
entre shopping lotado ocorrendo chorando
de dor dando um tapa na minha cara vai
manter acordado mas o shopping todinho e
cantando e dançando e gritando o campeão
para poder conseguir bater certo de um
mundial encolheu 827 longe mas tudo na
vida tem um começo eu tinha uma
mercearia
você chega lá pedir um misto quente eu
fazia 21 pra mim pra você
ele chegava lá pediu hamburgo fazia 21
pra mim pra ele e fui perdendo a noção
das coisas ea gente ficar nem ignorante
o palavrão quando chega a 100 quilos eu
tenho vergonha na cara
para minha sorte quando já estava com 98
quilos eu fui pegar um ônibus não
alcancei o ônibus quando cheguei em casa
de noite foi de capa dormir rolando na
cama queimação no estômago azia não
conseguia quando fui no banheiro me
olhei no espelho eu vi o time
transformado e falei para mim mesmo não
sendo gostar de ninguém vai gostar
resolvi calção tênis e comecei a
caminhar em volta do quarteirão da minha
casa lá todo dia de manhã eu acordava
dar uma voltinha de três quilômetros
duas voltas eu mudei meu hábito
alimentar todo dia arroz integral salada
e filé de peito de frango
ai meu irmão foi feito inscrição me
derem uma corrida do tipo 4 quilômetros
que eu ia morrer ali que estão vendo eu
ainda bem gordinho essa minha primeira
medalha eu falo da medalha mais
importante da minha vida porque foi o
primeiro passo que eu dei para
conquistar porque eu conquistei
sentindo o primeiro paciente não chega a
lugar nenhum e eu pude jogar eu fui
provas de 5 e 10 quilômetros
emagreci muito perder 28 que os em 10
meses em um momento muito especial foi
meu primeiro pódio e eu agradeço muito
ao flamengo
porque eu sou botafoguense estava
correndo na no hotel me passa um carro
com a camisa do flamengo foi não perder
para flamenguista não tá aí o passado
ele me passavam dando tiro ontem no
final ultrapassei ele ganhei dele quem
deprecia encarnado brincando com ele me
chama não podia subir no pódio é o único
que até na corrida o flamengo é parte do
meu botafogo ea gente
e depois disso foi para a meia maratona
maratona que é o sonho de todo até
correu a maratona e um dia eu recebi um
e-mail que tem uma coisa de 24 horas e
deixa eu tinha uns 400 metros e 24 horas
rodando na pista e ganha quem tem mais
volta você pode descansar pode caminhar
para isso não somando o número de voltas
eu fiquei pensando como é que pode um
ser humano correio24horas
um dia eu vou fazer o próximo de si mas
em tudo de olho mesmo e meio dia por um
dia porque queria nenhuma vez e agora
fui lá fiz a minha inscrição olhos
amigos amigos eu sei por que sacanear é
como debochando não ele vai correr duas
horas vai dormir 22 recorrente foi um
pai que foi o álbum geriátrico chegou na
hora ocorreu em 166 quilômetros em
primeiro lugar na categoria chorando
feito criança e aí eu descobri meu dom
aqui o que eu gostava né ver aquela
paixão que ele amor à primeira vista e
na área já foi logo a floresta amazônica
com reduzem em 50 km dentro da floresta
amazônica umidade 100% calor de quase 60
graus cecoi a solo de seu pé vai
cozinhando seu corpo mais cozinhando no
sexto dia de escola a sola do pé
a enfermeira tempo que remendar meu
tempo a chapecoense nos últimos 40
quilômetros de areia mas mesmo assim
graças a deus eu consegui trazer o
troféu brasil e depois disso ea prova
que mudou minha vida uma a gente tem uma
força mental que a gente desconhece a
gente aprende a trabalhar na sua boca
nós somos capazes de coisas que a gente
nem imagina mas é mais fácil de
concentrado no sofá uma desculpa não foi
deus que quis assim é mais fácil que a
gente correr atrás dos nossos sonhos e
quando fui passar prova a serra da
mantiqueira 207 km de montanha ou sobe
ou desce não tem parte plana
eu fui na loja sport rio de janeiro
pedir apoio lojista o cara me negou
apoio até aí tudo bem ninguém é obrigado
a apoiar ninguém
quando cheguei há pouco e aprova esse
cara está inscrita na prova que tinha
uma equipe de corrida de aventura e
quando ele viu o atleta super famoso na
época ele pegou tudo deles oferecendo o
cara quando olhei aquilo foi filha da
mãe pra mim o que dá um boneco cara
porque é famoso oferecendo tudo porque
um dia né
eu posso perder todo mundo esse cara não
perco não só que como não tinha dinheiro
eu tinha que correr com a mochila nas
costas não podia não tinha dinheiro para
pagar o carro de apoio tinha que não
tinha nada e possui como chuva nas
costas sempre que levar o necessário
para sobreviver
não sendo burro de carga com muito peso
não conta com ele e ele como tinha uma
equipe
tudo muito melhor da empresa dele tipo
nunca você pode levar sorvete pudim das
teve um monte de outras entretanto nada
mesmo
mas eu hoje não foi embora deixando pra
trás chovia muita chuva naquela serra da
mantiqueira que o lamaçal a lama foi
entrando no meu tempo mudou bolha não de
lá serão meus dedos
esse bumbum no meu pé esquerdo fincava
para continuar isso ele me passou foi
embora quando chegou no meio da prova o
cara me entrevistar e aí mas como é que
você tá aplicar num pé e acabou chegando
possam já que pode abandonar que não tem
mais jeito ele vira pra mim e fala o
joão o cara da loja a dez minutos em
outra frente quebradinho aérea energia
que eu precisava
quando ele falou isso eu joguei o grupo
alto e sair a todo atrás do cara aí
passei por ele
aí consegui chegar em sexto lugar na
prova quando cruzei a linha de chegada
eu soube que tinha uma mulher em perigo
só tinha uma mulher na prova estava em
perigo o diretor da prova acaba
procurando três atletas para resgatarem
ela eu fui interesse direto da prova que
ligou comigo vai cuidar de seu petróleo
e vai pro hospital
só que eu teria escondido no carro de
apoio com os outros três atletas
resgatar ela quando a gente encontra o
atleta eles foram pra fazê la desistir
até no carro embora porque não vim para
fazer desistir vem fazendo continuar
ele me chamaram de louco brigado com ele
foi embora e me largar sozinho com ela
eu corri mas com 11 horas com ela e
fizeram cruzar a linha de chegada
aí na porta e se podem ver
[Aplausos]
aí na foto eles podem vir a concluir em
chegar primeiro sozinho depois com ela a
linha dormindo então ea guiando ela e
woods élin carregar a mochila dela
acelera desclassificada então já que
ainda tudo dela pois o lado dela e ela
só tinha medo de sapo no caminho que
quero ficar legal do futuro com lucros
ea gente ficar com ela esse atleta
famoso tava na linha tinha de esperar da
gente ele bateu no meu peito e colocar
nunca vi ninguém fazer isso ninguém pode
ter certeza que a partir de hoje sua
vida vai mudar
o diretor da prova não pra mim existe
uma prova no deserto estados unidos que
nenhum brasileiro consegue se provou que
consegue é que eu fiz minha inscrição
para a prova só que essa prova é só os
80 melhores do mundo selecionadas e eu
nem sonhava em ser chamado até há pouco
recebi um e-mail perfil nem passaporte
eu tinha tinham passaporte correndo e
era obrigado a equipe de apoio não podia
correr com chuva nas costas
eu tinha dinheiro nem para pagar
despesas quanto mais na equipe
a mulher para debater na prova anterior
se ofereceu para fazer meu apoio pagando
de pesar dela o outro atleta que estava
lá também foi com a gente chegando longe
de toda a prova correndo na minha cara
não queria deixar a gente largar
programa impossível eu ocorrer através
do deserto com 12 pessoas no apoio e
depois de muita conversa e conseguiu
convencê lo e eu parei para ver no final
de tudo nós somos menores mas somos os
melhores conseguir trazer assim vela do
brasil
[Aplausos]
isso aqui
após 60 graus e foi em cima da linha
branca se não derrete a sola do tênis
unidade 0 mantendo sua e do deserto
estava sem graça correia 60 positivos
que eu fiz e fui correr 40 negativos
dívida do estado evocando a dar nome à
cidade de international falls minnesota
só que essa prova não pode ter apoio e
eu não falo inglês né
nessa prova sem querer puxar um trenó
com todo equipamento especial nesse
equipamento tem um saco de dormir que
suporta 40 negativos qualquer coisa de
quem está dentro dele minutos e foi
congelado
eu estava em segundo lugar na prova e
isso é madrugada me perdi fizeram um
buraco torci o joelho
voltei a ouvir continuam com junto ao
banco
o pé minha mãe não mexia mais não
conseguia pegar fechou em queda a bolsa
pode a bolsa em pegar o que ganha outra
dentro e os começou continuou o peito e
as costas eu falei morrer acabou eu vou
me arrastar para ter uma sobrevida não
me arrastando em campo um vídeo luizinho
lá embaixo
nesse âmbito a help help era um cara da
marinha americana e o cara morou em
salvador o cara falava português
só deus não tem explicação
o mais legal de tudo o que ele se
assustou e alguém falando português aqui
cada frame salvar esse rapaz que está aí
ó eu queria que minha filha casar se com
ele minha filha não quis eu podia se
tiver um filho pelo menos um nome dele
sem colocar aplicar me salva to morrendo
em todo o site do rio que me debatendo
todo e viu de novo viu pela moto de neve
também resgatar recusei debate se eu
subir na moto era de classificado
eu voltei para a prova e ainda cheguei
em quinto lugar na prova
essa é a minha foto mais famosa correu
mundo essa foto parece não mas sou eu e
eu com isso me tornei o primeiro atleta
de todo mundo a completar todas as
provas da copa do mundo de ambientes
extremos e quando vim de lá
um amigo meu foi o primeiro cara e
incentiva a correr quando estava
gordinha ainda ele se mudou pra búzios e
sim torná lo um pouco de você vem aqui
quanto saber que o brincando com ele
algumas jogo correndo e foi correndo aí
eu vim correndo realmente o que
aconteceu eu não quero correr correr o
cantor por uma causa e eu me sentir em
dívida com o hospital do câncer minha
mãe teve câncer foi curado pelo inca
itaipu no hospital do câncer onde eu
chego lá quatro acima loucura estão
comigo mas a primeira vez né
a mulher acreditava eu montei todo o
projeto foi correndo no rio de janeiro
larga na porta do hospital e na cruz
vermelha foi correndo até a praça de
blusa mude arrecadando fundos do
hospital do câncer e na chegada lá foi
fantástico e eu toco no coração que ele
começou por causas sociais não queremos
correr por medalha no troféu que correr
pra ajudar o próximo reconhecido mas só
que eu conheci igual às outras pessoas
me chama atenção para a filosofia ajudei
o time também já fiz uma prova que eu
corri 200 e r 400
aquela prova que o rei de bateria muito
corrido 17 eu vou tirar dessa vez
a dobrar eu corri 207 sozinho depois 17
com todo mundo 434 quilômetros
só que agora ficou fácil que não correu
como tinha nas costas bater a toyota
tinha quatro por quatro equipes de apoio
a pessoas também tinha deixa né ai 400
kms com carro de apoio fica fácil
depois disso que eu fiz voltei lá o
deserto vamos dobrar o deserto também
434 deserto quem tem meu apoio lá aquele
ossinho ldk de boné virado para a paixão
da minha vida na neve se ofereceu para
fazer meu apoio foi um amigo meu aqui no
rio de janeiro e um casal de americanos
quando souberam que estava indo lá para
dobrar essa prova se ofereceu para me
ajudar a pagar o meu hotel alugar meu
carro de apoio
depois de mandar e mail pra mim me
agradecendo que mude a vida deles e o
que marcou muito nesta prova 80
se ele fosse o primeiro a prova sozinho
depois eu faço com todo mundo porque já
está cansado nem conversando com os
outros atletas para ajudar nessa prova
como o diretor já tinha criado caso
comigo lá atrás eu falei não vou fazer o
seguinte vou correr a prova com todo
mundo e depois o deserto tarde ele não
pode me proíbe de passar eu fiz a prova
com todo mundo quando eu voltei todos
atletas e obrigados a passar por mim
porque só tinha aquele caminhão deserta
com a estrada no deserto e todos os
carros pararam passar muito boa para
muito do assunto tinha sobrado de comida
e bebida do carro deles
o primeiro que parou foi uma frase que
nunca vou esquecer que se está aprovando
o resto do mundo que é impossível não
existe e no final tem um senhor com a
perna mecânica com um pedaço de bolo na
mão uma lata de refrigerante na outra
pedindo por favor pouco meu bebê aquilo
para poder mostrar pra todo mundo que me
ajudou a fazer o que eu estava fazendo o
reconhecimento das pessoas e eu bati o
recorde de mais de 20 horas
junto a esses desafios
eu fiz alguns anos atrás uma prova de 24
horas em esteira é está em porto alegre
e o que me deu raiva que eu fiquei em
segundo lugar na prova o meu corpo
demora 12 horas para aquecer então posso
fazer nada curto porque a primeira em 12
horas são iguais até 12 horas da fama da
vontade pode passar mal da dor depois de
2 horas em caixa ficou dias correndo sem
parar de brincar amba
será que existe algo maior que 12 horas
em esteira aí comecei a pesquisar
descobrindo no livro do guinness que
existe um recorde mundial de sete dias
esteira 0 no francês de 822 quilômetros
ontem tudo um projeto só vai trazer o
videogame pra cara enviada três mil
euros por dia vai passar de avião hotel
alimentação 17 não tinham condições
outra maneira senão tudo shop lugar
aberto mas não pôde acompanhar ter que o
mapa os sete dias sem corte mudar pra
ele aí eu não tenho todo o projeto cinco
anos oferecendo para todas as empresas
todos os shoppings só não não posso
falar você tem que estar sempre pronto e
preparado a mesma oportunidade é única
na sua vida se passasse aproveitar
glórias e não vai ter outra tá vendo o
supermercado com esposa e um amigo que
não via há muito tempo estava tomando
cafezinho ct para tomar um café com ele
de pãozinho quanto tempo eu tenho um
sonho pra minha sorte estava sendo
pensando ou tendo um dom de chope que
tinha acabado de inaugurar aqui no rio
de janeiro a março vai ser agora e ligou
para o dono do shopping dia seguinte eu
cheguei lá
tratei tudo ea gente começou sete diane
está correndo lado passava que isso é
propaganda de esteira
o primeiro segundo ou terceiro dia aí
começou a parecer um programa de
televisão começou a chegar gente tinha
duas esteiras do meu lado procura do meu
lado é obrigado a depositar do câncer
gente é caso do homem o pacote de leite
em pó nessa brincadeira e aí contigo no
quarto de rompeu tendão meu pé virou a
bola aí o meu rendimento começou a cair
estava cinco quilômetros na frente do
reto e foi caindo foi caindo fiquei
muito para trás ocorria chorando de dor
aí quando choveu dormia 2 horas por
noite o último do word o campo marcelo
pois domingo é minuto nenhum senão você
não bate mais um recorde foi a noite 122
não viria a primeira noite e foi caindo
muito chegou na última noite o dono do
shopping dom pedro que a gente tem que
fazer
conseguiu bater esse recorde é um libelo
estacionamento nicho com a gente acha
que esse shopping uma capela o padre foi
lá rezou a missa bottle to bottle a
bíblia em cima da esteira começou a
chegar a gente gente parecia final da
copa do mundo o mais lotado que isso
aqui nunca vi uma pessoa no shopping
você pode ver aí nessa foto
e aí na última noite e ocorrência da
china já duas noites sem dormir com um
baile ano cheio de sons chorando de dor
o shopping souto cantando e dançando
piri de cinco minutos que aquele
silêncio total sentem na esteira cobrir
a cabeça com a toalha foi calor não dá
mais não tem mais condições ao olimpo
cantassem minha esposa chorando
vi aquela multidão tudo nunca lá do
final
não posso ser o causador da dengue da
princesa essas pessoas não sei de onde
veio dela eu comecei a tapa na minha
cara a tapa na minha cara despertei o
pessoal começou a vibrar subir na
esteira cinena toda o shopping veio
abaixo aí ocorrido um tapa na cara o
pessoal cantando e dançando em cachorra
a quando faltavam uns 100 metros finais
ou gritando é campeão é campeão e foi um
momento que nunca vou esquecer na minha
vida ea prova que você tem que estar
sempre pronta a aproveitar a
oportunidade e ter esse nome já estão a
fazer quatro anos agora com o nome está
no guinnes várias pessoas já tentaram
bater e graças a deus continua lá em seu
nome
[Aplausos]
há dois anos atrás eu estava treinando
na praia desculpa não vou cantar um
pedacinho da música minha voz horrível
mas sem reconhecer essa música eu estava
passando que hoje que está tocando
aquela música do frei já o você iria a
pé do rio salvador eu estava fazendo
bodas de prata pela esposa 25 anos de
casado
quando vi essa música tá aí vou correr
no rio salvador homenagem à esposa
montei todo projeto fui de fugir catar
salvador ba pelo percurso e 90 km por
dia só todo dia se tranquilo eu queria
contar com três já o queria me cantando
pra minha esposa minha chegada lá e
túlio
só que faltando um mês e pouco começou
dor de cabeça e febre dor de cabeça e
febre vai acertar no fim da faca que na
minha cabeça aquela punhalada na cabeça
eu fui duas vezes no hospital negociando
que era zico dando remédio pra dor não
passava a minha sorte a casa de saúde
são josé no rio estuda há cinco anos
para tentar descobrir porque o corpo
tanto eu fiquei muito amigo do
cardiologista de lá a esposa lembrou
nosso amigo produtor fabrício liguei pra
ele e pra cá agora em nove dias
internado a revirar do atual exame que
pode imaginar do mundo eu fiz e dava
tudo normal até que descobriu uma doença
auto-imune rara com 20 casos no mundo
combinada com a corrida que estava
cruzando artéria da minha cabeça eu
tenho carro carteria e até no corticóide
dose maciça corticóide vai deixando
alexandre é porque todo inchado e o
corticóide se pegarmos o corticóide
primeira coisa que está escrito lá
efeito colateral necrose da cabeça
femoral corticóide como a cabeça do meu
filho a quem copiou de seu diploma e não
conseguia levantar da cama eu acordava
de manhã e rastejando banheiro e um
filme na cabeça é minha história de vida
emocional mesmo ainda os cursos são dali
conforme andando e melhorando isso me
chamaram pra carregar a tocha olímpica
eu recusei que estava abalado
emocionalmente a minha esposa me deu um
esporro deixei de palhaçada
você tá indo que foi indicado pelo
brasil todo está sendo convidado porque
você artista nada eu carreguei chorando
o tempo todo de emoção e cada vez que o
corticóide foi piorando mas eu não
conseguia me levantar da cama
o meu cardiologista descobriu uma
prótese e lan que era muito boa que era
curta e era forte e eu me internei no
hospital para botar essa prótese
encontrava internado no hospital um
carrinho mandou a mensagem com o
espanhol tinha batido o recorde mundial
do caminho de santiago compostela é a
sócia espanha de 820 km
aí eu falei pra mim mesmo essa turma
escolheu a pessoa errada vou me curar e
voltar a bater esse recorde
botei a prótese sair do hospital no dia
seguinte eu já estava correndo na
piscina fazendo musculação fisioterapia
com 22 dias o filme a primeira corrida
de 5 pontos corridos muleta caminhando
com dez meses depois fui com minha
esposa e um bando de amigos loucos que
acreditaram no meu sonho e foi conduzido
junto a espanha e eu precisava de algo
mais para poder conseguir porque mesmo
botão da prova teórica estava
incomodando a coluna eu tenho que
conseguir algo bem costa não deixam de
existir jeito nenhum eu sou embaixador
do projeto no pará em paragominas que o
custo de cuidar de 160 crianças
especiais com síndrome de down paralisia
cerebral eu fiz uma aposta com vários
empresários se não bater seu recorde
mundial não é só completar não tinha que
bater o recorde mundial se não bater
certo mundial ninguém ajudava mas quase
um quarto de século mundial cada um ia
ter que pagar o tratamento de uma
criança deficiente durante um ano nesse
projeto e foi isso que me motivou eu
larguei e quem o senhor se alguém
conhece como em santiago de compostela
tem que seguir uma certa amarelo tempo
todo o recordista mundial anterior era
de lá que conheci o caminho eu não
conhecia o caminho tome perdia toda hora
tinha um terceiro dia eu estava muito
atrás dele me deu uma crise de choro foi
não vai dar mais para que o negócio no
corpo depois de 12 horas que começa a
pensar com ele
aí quando chegou depois do terceiro dia
comecei a correr foi voando e um momento
que nunca vou esquecer na minha vida foi
na madrugada do quinto ou sexto dia eu
comecei a correr cantando e dançando e
chorando de alegria e agradecendo a deus
por que me dá água pela segunda vez a
oportunidade de voltar a fazer o que eu
amo na imagem o recorde mundial em três
horas e ajudei 18 crianças a terem o
tratamento pago durante o ano inteiro
[Aplausos]
esse é o projeto juquinha quem tiver
curiosidade em tê-la bota projeto
luquinha que a minha paixão são crianças
especiais coisa fantástica aqui tem
também no rio tem um programa e rainha
do mar um evento de natação na praia eu
tenho um acordo com o pessoal do evento
tudo rei e rainha do mar o corpo 100 km
de areia pagar duas operações de coração
de duas crianças já paguei do 32o apenas
uma decoração que uma mãe que essa
postagem e agradecendo o filho dela foi
operado graças a minha corrida então
sabia que você correndo se está salvando
vida vale mais que qualquer regra de
qualquer troféu né
eu sou 11 anos voluntária do hospital do
câncer desde aquele rio bud ocorrido rio
são lourenço 300 quilômetros liga paraty
280 quilômetros já correu o mundo todo e
quando bate o recorde mundial da esteira
eu fui quando aqui no rio é básico você
não precisa pagar promessa e eu volto lá
naquele início lac se não fosse essa
medalha assim aí eu bem gordinho com 98
quilos
hoje meu nome já estaria quatro anos um
game então para você pode estar doente
com o desempregado pode ter morrido
alguém da sua família
dói dói chora chora como chorei muito
embaixo do chuveiro chora tudo tem sua
base de chuveiro respira fundo que o
mundo é cruel mundo quer saber se você
está feliz e triste então respira fundo
mete a cara e vencer ou vencer qualquer
um pode vencer não sou melhor do que
ninguém
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]